[Musique]
âgé de brest à besançon depuis la
rochelle jusqu'en avignon est là
[Musique]
là
la la la la bulle mais complété blu ray
disc d'un coup il a dit non c'est normal
t'as pas vu la gueule constipé des
hommes d'affaires on m'écoute je serai
pas à moi ce tournoi
là
[Musique]
la barbe à papa
au même mois
mon coeur est restée gemalto mari et a
vu l'accueil c'est chouette ça bouge en
plus comme si le corps de l'homme bouger
la fois qu'une cellule typhon nivat mari
ça suffit
oui mais
[Musique]
gros qu'ils ont dit les tout en hausse
wales et barbelés les rectiligne il ment
tour me cern me scrute cisaille me
décousent ne d'épaisses et c'est exact
je fais proéminence il trapu espère
émerger
pourtant à l'époque vous vouliez juste
je suis petit et précisément les membres
de ma famille pas plus alors ça c'est un
extrait du livre de raoul mille gros
heureux de louey je n'ai pas encore lu
mais salaires bienne n'a pas l'air
malheureux non il n'a pas l'air ce qui
devait bien parce que je suis dit merde
fois il di merda aux autres en sorte que
la chanson pour penser à des gros où les
gros il ya des congés les groupes
partagent leurs divisions et des gros
qui mériterait d'être maigre
enfin dans la société actuelle at elle
eu pas mal d'animations est rare je
crois bien unique la culpabilité
s'identifie avec l'autre surcroît par
surcroît pondérale ça veut dire avec
l'autre 3
c'est une belle réussite domination
sociale à les ratios social c'est pas un
mot un peu fort la grossesse n'est pas
une maladie en soi on peut être gros et
malades n'ont peut être mais des malades
et atteindre au moins jusqu'en automne
genre mais qui meurent mais qui meurent
avant l'âge c'est fou jour nous en sont
remplis et en milieu de temps en temps
il ya un gros puisqu'il est des groupes
qui survivent et qui survivent très
longtemps la jouer aussi une
réhabilitation du voyeur de manger sans
complexe et de bien se porter pour la
danse et bourrelets et à la photo raoul
mille là vous trouvez vous
bah
à
jacqueline
il est bon oui mais bon oui ben bongo
troubles un bon tu vois ce qu'il vit
encore
elles sont ce qu'elles sont moches ouled
maigre aux 100 q vous avec merde
crie-t-elle mer dom accros de la mode
aux mercenaires du bo mercantile nous ne
sommes pas des produits consommation
quelques plaintes à travers laquelle des
bellâtres nom alors je leur montrais
alors mon amant légèrement voyez vous
avez quand même une légère culotte de
cheval j'ai jamais faite cheval je
comprends pas ce que vous voulez dire
votre cheval de culotte votre pile au
mauvais cheval non claude de chemin
c'est disons c'est un problème
typiquement féminin
[Musique]
on a des problèmes on le travaille ça
non pas les impôts d'une serre parce que
au lieu d'avoir un pantalon qui descend
bien ça fait ça fait comme ça alors il
cessa esthétique un départ j'ai cru
remarquer ou dit non non c'est pas vrai
et robben s'est il trouvé ça triste et
non pas les queues de cheval
on va essayer je suis désolé rubens est
il le premier palais culotte de cheval
ip lait ip niel l'enrôlement comme comme
renoir mais pas la culotte de cheval pas
la sécurité ce pas là pour rien je
n'aime pas du tout comme ça mais est
alors si celle ci elle il ya des femmes
qui sont assez dingue je sentais rien
[Musique]
jamais je me mets celle répond aux
véhicules et votre machine
jamais jamais elsa vraiment je continue
à m'occuper de mon corps comme je le
fais une touche bien vous faire l'amour
le plus possible est terminée c'est tout
je mange que le jem et tout va bien on
sentait les baigneuses qui troublait le
coeur de renoir mais je ne laisserai
bien pu buzz qui rôdaient autour du chat
noir c'est voter ronde est sublime n'ont
plus cours nous vivons sous le régime au
du régime de la suppression de tout on
dit maigre comme régine on dit plus
maigre comme un impôt depuis combien de
temps êtes vous plus mince des années
raconter un peu comment es tu arrivé
j'étais très mince et puis petit à petit
en vieillissant j'ai pris du poids et
alors il est évident que pour nos jours
est due dès le début essayé de stopper
cette prise de poids et de de suivre un
régime je l'ait pas fait parce
qu'autrefois quand j'étais jeune je
mangeais du tout je faisais attention à
rien et ça m'a semblé très désagréable
de faire attention à quelque chose de
faire des exercices de gymnastique face
à ce qu'on mangeait de calculer c'est
ces calories cetera
oh je me suis dit ça va bien et puis
petit à petit puis ménages arrivent
malin j'arrive plus rhône est heureux on
a beau dire moi je
étant donné la situation et a donné la
société actuelle étant donné tout ce que
l'environnement
quelqu'un qui est fort ne peut pas
vraiment se sentir très bien dans sa
peau à moins d'être vraiment quelqu'un
de marginal
qu'ils s'en fichent tout est à chaque
jour la société vous fait penser que
vous à gauche
oui mais c'est vrai c'est pas de soi mal
dans ma peau
c'est ce dont je suis en mal dans ma
peau mais quand je passe c'est que je me
vois dans une glace par exemple
ben je ne me regarde pas parce que je
souffre certainement une esthétique que
je veux c'est que ça me gêne vous
regardait souvent avec la non justement
je ne regarde plus je regardais beaucoup
autrefois dans les dents les yeux des
autres non non non les îles les autres
non non non on n'y va être autre chose
on dit des autres
vous n'êtes pas le même problème puisque
au fond vous ne savez pas très bien ce
qu'être match n'ont jamais su ce
qu'était être mince puisque la [ __ ]
d'enfance enfin j'ai été classé dans la
catégorie des grosses et puis ça par
rapport à vos camarades d'école tout ça
enfin c'est c'est plutôt la grosse déjà
toujours à la longueur
oui oui aujourd'hui d'autres surnoms
encore plus méchant c'était l'année
non c'était la grosse surface ça
suffisait ça suffit je crois pour pour
enlever pour m'enlever un peu de sûreté
enfin la sûreté qu'on ne peut pas voir
partir de quel âge on peut à grosse mais
je pense que je crois qu'à trois ans -
enfants qui est un peu gros il n'est pas
gros il époux pas il est un petit bébé
ou tout beau tout joufflu comme ça et
puis à partir de 7 ans 8 ans n'a plus
droit d'accès voilà ce que vous avez
beaucoup souffert tous ces mots vous
avez entendu notre pretty petit je crois
vous allez encore en mémoire
oui enfin de toute façon je crois que
même maintenant dans la rue on est
toujours à gré c'est quoi par les
regards par même par les mots mais des
mots même pas did you on les entend
quand même qu'en laissant gens venir
votre enfance quand on entend les gros
en font ce qu on se dit quand je serai
grand je ne serai plus gros en oui je
croirais vous les voulez les entend bon
je sais pas je me suis installé ici
jouent souvent on se tenait toujours
enfin aux parents comment se fait-il
mes parents je crois qu'ils n'ont pas
fait attention je pense que je faisais
partie intégrante de la famille et vous
voici ce n'était pas un problème pour
eux moi je me dis la grosse non non
alors ils l'ont dit mais
mais c'était affectueux s'était pas
c'était pas comme comme les enfants
d'entourage les camarades puisque c'est
un mot qui peut être dit avec affection
oh oui oh oui je crois oui parce que je
crois que mes parents m'aient mais pour
moi elle pas pour mon corps enfin je
crois que c'est ça le plus important
c'est d'être aimé pour pour soi vos
parents j'ai mis mes parents m'ont
jamais reproché les trop grosses et
votre mari n'ont donc anglais les
rencontres
est ce qui vous est déjà arrivé d'aimer
votre corps oui quand mon mari l'ait moi
je laime aussi voulait mais grâce à lui
oui je laime grâce à lui et c'est
peut-être pour ça un peu que je
m'agrippe à quoi je parle mais toute
série crois que ça m'aide à ne pas
oublier la un peu tout seul est ce qu
est ce que vous pouvez aimer votre corps
seul sol devant une nacelle
c'est à dire juge non je crois pas façon
je te plaît comme ça ouais mais il ya
quand même qu'il ya toujours
roy déjà bondé dans ton sens parce que
c'était très long terme social tu as
l'impression est bon avoir une femme
bosser comme le basket de chevaux des
rolls
je sais pas vous moi je m'en fous j'aime
bien les deux chevaux avaient trois de
ses plus importants le sait pas c'est
pas le lecomte le contenant est
important c'est le contenu
non parce que cyann ou des deux sont
importants qu'ils ont plus peur il ya de
lagrasse partout même chez les grands je
parle du point de vue esthétique
montbard
j'aime bien j'aime bien que ça soit
bourbon - dont la belle droite est belle
même ryan main ça trouble jeudi kyla
votre problème
mon problème c'est
ça dépend où je suis mais en 1978 en
france aux candidates à sucre hausse ou
baisse anormale
d'ailleurs je suis arrivé en france il
ya dix ans du nord au 12 vient jamais
été comme tout le monde m'est arrivé en
france qui a peut-être le fait que la
femme moyenne française clémence le plus
petit et plus mince mais ça me
dérangeait pas tellement je me suffisait
en moi mais c'est quand il faut
s'habiller en france c'est un problème
où elle dit au quartier latin je me sens
je me suis enfin au quartier latin si je
vais aller acheter un pantalon je vais
dans un magasin j'ai c'est bon je suis
quand même pas un naïf je commence par à
42,44 je prend 1,46 et quand même quand
s'ils savent à certains endroits mais
pas d'autres et quand d'une bonne femme
dit non mais il faut may cry à madame
pense je suis écoeuré y figurait pas ce
que je peux pas m'habiller puisque
furieuse contre la bonne femme
je me faisais pas ruiner non non j'ai
pas envie d'entrer dans une espèce de
compétition intra femme ou rares à moi
je te réveilles mettriez vous vous
devriez mai
si vous pouviez rajeunir ça se ferait
pas de mal ça veut dire je veux pas
rentrer dans ce genre de truc mais ça
m'agace profondément
il avait des grosses tailles le résultat
par exemple
alors
sa quarante deux 42 morts
ça y est on va essayer avec h messieurs
vos taille s'arrêtent s'arrête la vente
de 40
[Musique]
les chefs oublier poser une question
j'ai dit oui je vais vous poser une
question est ce que vous engageriez une
vendeuse obèse sue c'est une bonne
vendeuse pourquoi pas c'est à vomir
je croyais j'avais paloise à certaines
normes esthétiques enfin il faut pas une
loi il faut pouvoir percer des choses de
la maison oui parce que la boue rouge
peut penser aller les choses large mais
si si la mode étroite je pourrais pu
reporter donc je pourrais tu portais des
choses de la maison alors à ce moment de
son lancement
[Musique]
je n'ai pas peur de me mettre llodra
voici venue l'heure de qui lors de quoi
j'ai regardé d'autres
vite vous mettez à l'eau dans ces cas-là
économie non alors j'aime trop la
piscine commandant couper toute
adhérence et autres et leurs affaires
est ce que vous sentez le regard des
hommes sur ses cuisses que vous trouvez
trop grossi non ce sont elles les
baigneuses qui troublait le coeur de
renoir mais jeunesse vient pulpeuse qui
ronde est autour du chat noir
ces beautés ronde est sublime n'ont plus
cours nous vivons sous le régime du
régime de la suppression de tout on dit
maigre comme régine on dit plus maigre
comme un regret j'ai l'impression
jacques une fois que vous écoutez bien
parce que j'aime le hockey comme adams à
peu près exactement le même genre
d'effort que vous pour rester
elle pour rester comme elle est et vont
pour gagner ah oui tout à fait oui j'ai
suivi plusieurs régimes et c'est tout à
fait ça enfin attention à équilibrer il
faut équilibrer l'alimentation
bon c'est pareil enfin penche trop le
lendemain on se restreint et même gêné
actuellement oui c'est ce qui est très
bon pour la santé
finalement il faut pas le faire tous les
jours mais par exemple j'ai une fois par
mois
ne pas manger boire de l'eau c'est très
bien c'est très bien tout se remet en
place
c'est très bien ce que j'essaie et c'est
ce que je fais c'est ce que je fais donc
vous n'êtes pas même en permanence
obsédé par ça enfin jeu c'est à dire que
j'ai une discipline de vie comme ça
général les femmes qui viennent chez
vous aime bien qu'on se trouve leur
corps oui c'est pas désagréable d'être
pris en charge pendant une heure sont
pas folles des multi piqûre surtout la
première fois mais je veux pas très mal
tout le monde fait c'est plus
impressionnant de voir la seringue avec
un peu rébarbatives
mais les aiguilles sont courtes ce
n'était pas si mal quand même mieux
qu'on s'occupe d'elle
oui et c'est toujours agréable on est
gentil avec elle ça fait maigrir se veut
rien dire non donc on essaie de rétablir
de benoît thieulin la wii le calme en
obtient de bons résultats qui ce durant
cm l'important c'est de son corps
l'important c'est les gars vous avez dit
machine à laver vous vous habillez en
prêt-à-porter vous vous êtes pressé on
fait partie d'un système
ça serait un peu agressif de tout
refuser de dire je refuse de ressembler
à acquis mais je ne suis pas agressif
moi je donnerai bien sans vie à ursula
andress si un institut à paris me disais
que je dirai tout de suite parce que ça
doit être agréable dette dette belge
d'agréable on croyait on pensait il ya
cinq ans elle peut pas devenir plus mais
enfin c'est pas possible mais si l'année
d'après ils sont encore plus mais pas
cette année c'est vraiment
je veux ça fait six ans on voit que
c'était vrai personnage et ont servi
pour faire les photos
et puis il ya une espèce de trucages et
dans sa main ça on a même mais
maintenant on enlève les couleurs
premier pas qui les considèrent comme
des objets enfin des objets de mode des
objets de plaisir a lancé vous demande
pas de penser mais il faut quand même
faut quand même avoir quelque chose dans
la tête c'est à dire pas tellement
m'enfin je voulais pouvoir se concentrer
ils font comment comprendre ce couple
lundi
quel est votre plat préféré louis saha
journaliste monde et aux menaces ya une
grande enquête sur tout ce qui existe en
matière d'amaigrissement donc est un peu
critique et j'aurais d'abord savoir
pourquoi vous êtes intéressé à ce sujet
alors c'est pas une enquête sur tout ce
qui existe en matière d'aménagement
c'est une enquête spécifique sur les
moyennes chimiques nocifs de maigrir que
j'ai fait est en fait mon point de
départ remonte à la certitude que j'ai
vu ce sont des informations qu'on m'a
donnée sur laquelle il ya des morts il
ya des moments ça ça a été mon point de
départ
les morts étaient mauvais à partir du
moment où j'ai su qu'il y avait débord
pas seulement des gens qui deviennent
toxicomanes
enfin qui supporte mal ce genre de
traitement gainey médias en plus des
morts j'ai décidé de faire cette enquête
qui m'a pris beaucoup de temps à la
panoplie de tous ses moyens curieux
utilisé par certains médecins pour
fermer hier les gens qui est il assez
surprenant et j'en ai trouvé un qui est
une technique bien particulière qui
consiste à faire des prélèvements de
peau de ternes et à fabriquer un vaccin
vous pouvez raconte exactement comment
s'est passée cette visite parce que se
passait pas sûr alors il m'a mis un
voile sur la tête ce qui fait qu'il
n'est absolument plus rien vu de la
suite des événements il m'a mis sur la
peau là avec une banque genre assez
petit sid quelque chose qui a fait un
froid terrible en fait qui me brûlait 0
pt
les producteurs ne respectais beaucoup
parce qu'il médiatement il a enfoncé
dans ma peau à un instrument métallique
et alors là j'ai vraiment crier parce
que je me suis dit que c'était
absolument piégé s'est dit vous les
parties m'éliminer pas que ce nouveau
parti est ouvert pour des mesures fermes
il a refermé effectivement il m'a fait
deux points de suture et lesquels je me
suis retrouvée au bout de cinq minutes
elle est naïve bailly vous avez été
nanti d'une cicatrice est aussi du nord
de lancer est là je lui demander quand
même d'abord ce qu'il allait faire avec
ça parce que je pensais pas que c'était
tout de suite qu'il allait me faire la
bbox il m'a dit avec ça c'est très
simple faire un vaccin on va mélanger
vos cellules dans une certaines
pharmacies dont on va vous donner
l'adresse avec du sérum physiologique de
l'eau et vous vous injecterait ça vous
même tous les jours voilà mais il ne se
contente pas de prescrire ça il m'a dit
vous viendrez d'un bijou rechercher
votre ordonnance
on verra je sais plus trop comment ça
s'est passé et sur cette ordonnance
qu'ils avaient j'ai pas une dizaine de
pages il ya non seulement la méthode
d'injection enfin les détails sur
l'injection du vaccin en guinée il ya
aussi tout le trio chimiques habituel et
celui là qui est un perfectionniste sans
doute il ya rajouté l'halopéridol du
cardinal de la cortisone et de la
digitaline voilà tout se détendre se
décontracte les chocs pression sur vos
tempes augmentant de relaxation
tout est calme enfants
vous allez sentir votre bras devenir
aide toi tellement raide plus en plus
raide
plus rien ne peut le faire plier
votre bras gauche à santorin de viread
totalement reid
plus rien ne veulent faire plier votre
jambe droite reedy votre pied s'allonge
ready davantage et approfondie votre
relaxation votre virement gauche
davantage tendues de plus en plus tendue
et vous sentez votre dos se contracter
tout votre corps quand se soulèvent
devient totalement rêve totalement raid
totale règne dans les cas d'obésité
rebelles c'est obésité dont j'ai dit
tout à l'heure qu'elle avait fait
l'objet de nombreuses tentatives de
nombreux échecs dans ces états il faut
donc aller plus loin et il faut pousser
la technique jusqu'à l'obtention de la
transe profondeur
vous voyez des aliments qui vous sont
nocifs des gâteaux du sucre vous les
voyez ces éléments vous savez qu'ils
vous sont nocifs et vous n'en avais plus
envie
à partir de maintenant vous passerez
indifférente à côté de ces aliments
vous n'aurez plus envie
cette remarquable efficacité qui avait
été prévu par pierre janet ne doit pas
faire oublier qu'elle comporte un
certain nombre de dangers puisque nous
savons tous qu'il est impossible de
prévoir les distorsions que peuvent
subir des suggestions
quelle qu'elle soit lorsqu'elles sont
faites à une personnalité dont on ne
connaît jamais tout à fait les
profondeurs des états de conscience
tout va bien
et
ouais
tout est redevenu normal à saisir je
suis arrivé à paris en vue trouve un
miel maigrir
j'ai assisté à un congrès était question
d'un vieillissement par l'hypnose est
entre autres il a été dit à ce congrès
que la frigidité était une conséquence
de gens visitent et qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
dubois vélib ne vous rafraîchir la
précitée cause de cancer
bien il a été bien observé depuis
démontré scientifiquement que en moyenne
les filles et les femmes fortes sont
plus sensibles au monde extérieur que le
femmes dans mon coin moyens ce qui veut
dire qu'elles sont plus sensibles aux
bruits à la douleur cousinage est aussi
évidemment à l'alimentation et il semble
que les hommes elles une attitude
ambiguë que pour des raisons sociales
ils préfèrent être vu avec deux femmes
minces les plus flatteurs et je crois
que pour une partie d'entre eux ils
préfèrent être au lit avec des seins
puis de lui mais je n'en sais rien ce
n'est pas du tout ce n'est pas du tout
là une démonstration scientifique
puisque à la connaissance des enquêtes
n'ont pas été suffisants si on voit
compte que vous l'êtes pas grosse séparé
vous aideront la deuxième façon de
servir d'hypnose cd donner des ordres
hypnotique pour manger moins alors ça
nous l'avons essayé ça ne marche pas au
delà desquels plaisir quelques jours
c'est là consiste à dégoûter les gens de
la nourriture c'est extraordinairement
peu efficace et puis c'est cheap des
critiques a déjà été fait par zygmunt
frei à la fin du 19e siècle il s'est
installé comme hypnotiseur à vienne et
c'est en voyant que les symptômes
ressortait de tous les côtés quand il
les a ni
l'hypnose qu'il a commencé à faire autre
chose et bien c'est vous qui avez les
chiffres voulez vous nous donner le
chiffre hui de new york que vous publiez
dans dans votre livre ou en s'aperçoit
que dans les classes riches de new york
on trouve 37 % de femmes maigres 58% de
famille normale et 5% de baisse alors
que dans les classes les plus pauvres on
trouve seulement 9 % de maigres 61 % de
femmes normales et 30% de neige lorsque
les gens lorsque des femmes jeux sont
comblés par la naissance l'argent le
choix masculin les types d'activités la
frustration alimentaire l'air devient si
naturel si agréable car les compensées à
chaque fois par deux succès niveau que
non seulement elles ne viennent pas
forte
mais vous avez vu dans plus d'un tiers
des cas elles ne viennent maladie main
maigre et par contre chez les femmes les
moins privilégiés de new york devenir
fort franchement obèses
elle devient presque une norme sociale
cette différence très importante sur un
milieu social n'est pas vrai pour les
hommes et un banquier est souvent gras
gros et séraphine est toujours mince moi
je voulais vous demander que quelque
chose sur les
différents régimes j'ai suivi un régime
l'année dernière puis j'ai perdu 5,6 kg
de soi disant homéopathie on a chez un
docteur qui discute avec vos dix minutes
et je vous prends 150 francs vous envoie
dans une pharmacie spéciale par ailleurs
une fois les temps ces femmes au sénat
et acheter plein de choses qui sont
quand j'ai demandé si c'est ce que
c'était on m'a dit que c'était de
l'organe aux thérapies cher très cher
enfin pour le premier médicament j'ai
payé 130 francs 30 65 francs et fage et
le jeune j'ai noté les produits qui sont
là dedans je veux savoir ce que vous en
pensez
ça a marché une pompe pour 5,6 kg ça ça
a été efficace devant je pense que deux
points très importants pays en plein
développement
la deuxième manche on pense énormément
de mal
les extraits thyroïdiens qui font brûler
de la graisse mais aussi du muscle qui
énerve équidés trappe peu ou prou la vie
psychologique du sujet et les
fonctionnements des cinglante
c'est aussi des palpitations des
tachycardies les insomnies à ce que
l'enfant trop parfois d'ailleurs dans
ces mauvaises ordonnance on ajoute un
tranquillisant bas de suppôt calme
mesure de détrôner
deuxièmement vous avez des diurétiques
vécu très souvent ce n'est pas dangereux
car on ajoute du potassium que cela fait
mille naît et surtout ceux très
spectaculaire quelqu'un qui prend des
diurétiques n'a jamais prêt avant peut
perdre 3 4 5 kg de poids par jour
mais il va de soi qu'il ne puisse pas sa
graisse et puis il y a les anorexigènes
le coupe faim
le couple sont d'autant plus
intéressants qu'ils ont des effets
psychologiques en même temps ils ont
fait fort is an ils rendent heureux non
seulement on n'a pas
en plus on est content content ronde ans
et il y as depuis les amener des
véritables toxicomanie de gens qui
deviennent des toxicomanes sans le
savoir raffine c'est un tape taquet
température s'est pas trop chaud
non c'est pas
et
ça va sécher et ça fait une pellicule
mans vous sentez bien là a bien été
fermé en mai comme ça n'aide pas la
pousse
ces véhicules dépouilla de l'air à
l'intérieur d'une technique nouvelle
on enlève y est c'est tellement c'est
tout on laisse 35 minutes comme ça dans
on
ils vous laissent les mains nues ont
transpiré dantesque
quand vous faites un navire turc a pour
le coeur ça fait dangereux précaution
temps
bon
unis par
ils peuvent vous sauver
corsan t-on enfin quand on vous en fait
la gym natif sans gloire au contraire
tout bouge là vraiment on fait
travailler tout santé bougez là quand
ils seront des squelettes des fantômes
des purs esprits aux mélèzes et
femmelettes se font peut-être encore en
vie mais l'on entendra les couples dans
le plus petit des ans se dira comme on
est souple ceux d'iran comme on est bon
mais quand on mangeait bien sûr on se
tenait quand même plus chaud cette
chanson sans encombre à qui la chante
aura sans doute avec moi cdb news vous
voulez venir assez des baigneurs je me
suis baigné des hommes
je peux marcher je trouve que j'ai
beaucoup
j'aime tellement ce schème bien j'aime
bien parce qu'il ya beaucoup de bleus
puisque les corses ont beau quand même
oui à 102 106 les baigneuses les
fameuses baigneuses à nous non si pour
les nuls ac c'est celui là
ah ouais les grandes
non
j'y connais rien je connais rien toute
façon oui celui là et ça c'est très bon
oui c'est bien d'un cheikh malsain belle
oui ce sont des femmes qui sont pas
comme elle c'était au début du siècle un
peu ce sont des femmes qui sont chauds
poubelle mais ils sont bien en chair et
c'est pas du tout la fin de même du
modèle de forme
philippe 118 maintenant
ouais
parce que maintenant
c'est réconfortant bah oui c'est
réconfortant de voir que il n'ya pas que
novare et qui trouve les fang rosen et
aussi des peintres qui les apprécier et
puis je pense que ça correspondait à une
certaine image de l'époque alors que
maintenant l'image s'est passé est
extraordinaire mais oui la qualité le
voir par exemple ces deux derniers
tableaux d'une femme avec vraiment de
très grosses fesses est vraiment de très
gros ventre est ça fait plaisir à voir
pour vous j'entends un bruit ou je
trouve que même si raison des très gros
ventre très gros je trouve pas que ce
soit tellement gros jeu trop belle une
poubelle s'emballer c'était
alizée ça et c'est qu'elles sont belles
sont pas obèses du tout elles elles ont
des tailles très marin qui l ont pas des
saints and mail ont évidemment un ventre
assez proéminent mais c'est je pense un
symbole la maternité
tu veux bof c'est pas parce que moi je
suis content itinérante en peinture mais
je crois qu'elles sont belles parce
qu'elles sont bien proportionnées je
vois il s'emballe comme ça de l'état
comme ça
j'apporte ans
bon alors monsieur le professeur nous
sommes venus vous voir pour vous
demander si on l'aide à devenir à
s'accepter comme elle est une femme à
forte baisse au fond ça revient à la
marginaliser la société actuelle mais
madame les valeurs de notre société ne
sont pas uniquement des valeurs
esthétiques et vous pouvez très bien
avoir d'autres corde à votre arc
nous ne sommes pas uniquement une sorte
de terrain de chasse ou des mâles
poursuivre les femelles et encore il ya
des femmes qui ont une vie amoureuse
parfaitement bien remplie bien qu'ayant
quelques kilos en trop
il ya des hommes pour qui une femme
grâce est quelque chose de rassurant
donc tout n'est pas perdu
effectivement il ya un modèle la
plastique fins de l'esthétique féminin
qui découlent de de toute la publicité
des magazines et hydra et madame ça
découle aussi d'un mouvement féministe
que j'approuve entièrement c'est à dire
que avant les rôles de la femme de
l'homme était très différent et la femme
était au fond cette espèce tofu qui est
fécondé par un spermatozoïde de sa
fonction essentielle était
naissance à des enfants et c'est après
la guerre de 14 qui a commencé en
maintenant nos pays
une revendication qui a été celle de la
garçonne de victor marguerite et c'est à
partir de ce moment là que sont apparus
dans la peinture des femmes minces sur
tout à fait des mannequins d'aujourd'hui
parait-il tout à fait raisonnable que
qu'une personne obèse
homme ou femme puisse dire je suis bien
dans ma peau je suis heureux d'être gros
parfaitement bon et il y a eu des
périodes où on ne s'occupait pas de ça
et quand vous voyez les tableaux de
rubens constaté que les femmes sont même
très forte et qu'elle paraisse rain man
très joyeuse alors moi j'aime mieux des
gens qui sont plutôt opulent et qui sont
contents de vivre plutôt que des êtres
filiforme et dont les yeux sont rivés
dans passionnel d'une bleue des vosges
sur la balance
[Musique]
un plagiat nous espérer très honnêtement
non parce que j'aurais donné dans les
magasins de vêtements comme ça c'est
trop classique par rapport à mon âge
faisant du plastique
vous avez déjà la fin maintenant les
choses bougent la distributions
s'améliorent à ce niveau là et je crois
que on perçoit des signes de réveil chez
les fabricants petit à petit j'ai plus
grand estime un peu louis qualité
cuisson non ce ne peut pas être ça
bonjour monsieur
on était venu c'est pour maigrir mais on
a l'impression que c'est pour te plutôt
pour des monsieur muscles comme un peu
peur puisque c'est à dire que
on avait vu un gymnase alors on s'est
dit on va aller voir ce que c'est oui
ici c'est un gymnase pour de la
gymnastique dans le ciel génocide
musculation pas spécialisée dans la
médiation
pas du tout oui mais en face à ed c'est
quand même à maigrir nous déjà si vous
étiez susceptibles de venir
ces gymnases il faudrait déjà un
certificat médical attestant que vous
êtes en condition physique pour faire de
la gymnastique d'entretien
[Musique]
alors
cet acteur joue de sa voix est ce que
vous pensez qu'on peut être à brosses et
heureuse d'un d'annotations société
actuelle mais dans la société actuelle
ben je le crois certainement
on croyait alors je crois qu'il ya pas
mal de gens en gros qui sont toujours eu
mais malheureusement il y en a pas assez
parce que la société
de ce point de vue là est extrêmement
tôt précise je pense qu'il ya une espèce
de racisme anti gros que je considère
pour ma part comme insupportable et que
l'on parle tout le temps du droit à la
différence le droit à être différents
les uns des autres
eh bien il ya une espèce de
totalitarisme qui veut que chaque
individu soit en totalité identique aux
voisins et même dans sa forme et même
dans son poids la société et répressive
la société essaie de culpabiliser les
gros et les gros doivent absolument se
déculpabiliser séjour ajouter un mot il
voir se déculpabiliser d'autant plus que
le plus souvent ne sont pas responsables
de leur obésité
ils sont pas responsables de leur
obésité parce qu'il ya une énorme
prédispositions qui est familiale qui
est génétique et puis enfin des tas
d'autres facteurs sur laquelle je vous
permettant à l'enfant
enfin parce que comment peut-on certains
enfants ne deviennent pas vrai
oui oui dans la première enfance
deux types d'erreurs très grave
peut-être commis une première erreur
c'est une erreur quantitative c'est de
trop d'années à manger à son enfant une
espèce de suralimentation globale alors
cette souris mentation global l'ag de
vous faire un véritable cours
cette suralimentation global on l'a fait
beaucoup moins maintenant qu autrefois
parce que tout de même les pédiatres
commence renseigner les parents
cette surévaluation globale agit de deux
manières d'abord parce qu'elle augmente
le nombre des cellules adipeuses et
ensuite l'adulte qui sera cet enfant
grandit devenu adulte aura trop de
cellules adipeuses qui ne demanderont
qu'à se gonfler donc on aura créé là
quelque chose presque d'un délit bible
et puis cette suralimentation global un
autre ennui c'est qu'elle crée ce que
nous appelons un conditionnement et en
langage plus simple on peut simplement
dire une habitude habitudes alimentaires
ont créé un conditionnement à manger et
c'est ainsi que dans certaines familles
on se transmet des habitudes
alimentaires est fautive et y est très
très quand l'enfant est très jeune puis
leur a coûté 2,7 suralimentation
globalia deuxième point qui est plus
plus subtil mais il très très
passionnant c'était une erreur
qualitative alors c'est quand la mère ou
le substitut de mer qui gardent l'enfant
pour s'en débarrasser ou parce que c'est
plus commode va donner un morceau de
chocolat va donner quelque chose à
manger va donner une gratification de
bouche un moment précis où l'enfant en
réalité désirent une caresse désirent
une présence désir du temps donné alors
ça c'est très grave parce qu'alors il se
crée chez l'enfant une confusion dans
ces perceptions et plus tard quand il a
grandi et qu'il devient adolescent il
croit qu'il a faim de nourriture alors
qu'il a faim d'affectivité professeur je
vais simplement vous posez une gagnée
question les spécialistes dont vous êtes
sont tous d'une grande humilité sur ce
problème et a clos fo ils savent qu'ils
ne savent pas grand chose
est ce qu'au moins les charlatans qui
chacun attende de l'amaigrissement qui
cherchent un peu dans toutes les
directions et quelquefois une façon
dangereuse non pas au moins eu le mérite
de proposer des solutions très diverses
et peut-être de découvrir à jour une
solution efficace
alors je crois que modestie peut-être
mais je crois qu'il faut pas exagérer on
approche de la compréhension du problème
et qu'on sait que tout ce passe dans
cette fameuse région hypothalamique
alors pour prendre un exemple tout à
fait expérimental si on prend un animal
qui a une régulation de poids déterminé
il a son poids il à son coefficient
personnel d'utilisation des aliments si
on provoque une lésion expérimental de
l'hypothalamus
il va devenir obèse et quand il sera
devenu obèse à un certain niveau
d'obésité il ne grossit plus et il a une
dysrégulation hypothalamique mais régler
tout de même règle est réglé à un autre
niveau
par conséquent nous approchons de la
connaissance du phénomène
[Musique]
alors je vous remet la médaille voilà je
vous la croche là vous voyez d'ailleurs
el hamdi strass ça veut dire aux
affaires du plus de 10 kg 1 12 kg c'est
bien là cinq ans que j'ai mon pot idéal
en ayant appris à manger
c'est pour moi une traite quelque chose
de très important
[Applaudissements]
pendant quinze ans de ma vie j'ai
vraiment été très mal dans ma peau parce
que j'ai grossi 14 kg 14 kg hélène aussi
je vois que vous avez bien faire du
racontez-nous samedi veut c'est
extraordinaire oui vous avez bien vu
combien dit voleurs je pense 7 kg 7 kg
[Musique]
madame shannon de route elle très bon
très bien s'est vu la bête qu'est ce que
c'est
allez il faut pas y toucher c'est roman
de jeu seul gagnant c'est maintenant
vous l'avez vu
quand on y pense vraiment quelle société
c'est pas possible si jamais jamais une
copine du sud
j'ai rien aux tunisiens me voit et c'est
vraiment c'est un scandale notre façon
oui il me semble quand même facile si
c'est ça qu'on appelle le progrès le
fait enfin le progrès égale avoir des
problèmes
c'est vraiment des problèmes de luxe que
nous avons deux d'aller faire des
recherches de mettre un fric fou
les instituts de beauté je sais pas quoi
pour m'écrire un an que tout ce qu'il ya
des gens qui crèvent de voir ce qu'on a
entendu ce matin qu on utilise des
ordinateurs qui coûte très cher à coude
qui en payent pas au nombre au micro
secondes les ordinateurs qu'on utilise
mais il n'ya pas que les ordinateurs oui
tu sais au micro cyclone seconde que ça
ce que ça se calcule à l'insu loutan de
microsecondes enfin tant de temps
d'ordinateurs il n'y a pas que ça il ya
les programmes
n'empêche que toutes les trois vous êtes
quand même plus ou moins préoccupés par
le fait de maigrir bien sûr je trouve
qu'il ya un décalage telle entre mettre
un ordinateur et le fait que la ville a
changé entre sfr et non seulement d'un
tiers monde mais calais dans les
banlieues d'android oui il faut même pas
les le monde l'immigré 6e puis s'ils ont
les occupent s'ils ont un ordinateur
alors vous n'êtes pas fâché que des gens
s'intéresse au problème de la mairie ces
deux épiciers reconnaît en baisse
maintenant on a trouvé d'autres épicier
qui s'appelle à l'institut de beauté
qu'on a vu de très spacieux aussi can
disputée sous pour nous rendre au moins
deux mois sans qu'il a rendues obèses
la société et les coca cola et le peanut
butter comme un jeu stage mutu a été aux
états unis je sais pas si tu as vu un
peu l'obésité lapin a cessé même passé
tout le monde est obèse
c'est encore des choses des choses
défendu à la fête la fête
aujourd'hui on fait la fête il ya
longtemps que vous avez décidé de passer
outre aux choses défendu oui oui parce
que j'estime que c'est bon mangez c'est
vivre et puis je sais c'est non
seulement se boit frais mais c'est une
forme de dames de relations sociales
lors pas c'est aussi la fête mais bien
sur leurs pas ça ça a toujours été la
fête
1 c'est l'occasion de réunions
l'occasion de parler l'occasion d'être
entre soi c'est pas simplement manger
manger
[Musique]
comme la moelle c'était le auchan ce
matin toute la matinée que vous avez
fait ouais moi quand je suis rentré je
crois trouver jardin
[Musique]